um we communicate so well that you know
we are allowed hall passes well i'm
sorry what yeah it's an open
relationship and unless you open a
relationship because i don't know like
um like he's like only i get the hall
pass no but he said no but you would too
like if you go on a girls trip you know
whatever happens happens i don't gotta
hear about it and this is the first day
this is the first day oh look
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to big mood
hi
we have our beautiful guest nikki blades
here with us hello ladies it's gonna
look beautiful as usual oh you guys got
the green member oh a little jade moment
going on for those of you
i'm wearing black yeah you're wearing
black
i got a jade necklace oh there it counts
it counts
we're all somehow coordinating so yeah
we have our beautiful other host hi it's
me gina gina dan your beautiful hair
hello and then we got our other host
beautiful team thank you just the tits
yeah i love that just a tip
just a tiffany
[Music]
thank you so much so today we're going
to be talking about um
unconventional hacks that couples uh do
to it's like
unconventional relationship hacks oh
like keep your relationship nice and
spunky and oh well i'm ready to learn
about this
because i am not in a relationship but i
am high five yeah ready to learn but you
have been in relationships sure have and
they were not conventional at all
okay
well yeah because these are
unconventional yes yes here i can tell
you what don't work
don't cheat yeah there we go there's
that
there's a hat don't cheat there's a hack
don't cheat yeah
don't put yourself in another woman when
you're with me look at that there you go
look at that crazy wow we're not upset
at all yeah
i'm good
i'm ready for the next though so to my
future husband watch this episode yep
and uh make sure not to cheat it's real
simple because i don't want to go to
jail again
i've never been to jail
allegedly come on now right okay
all right so the first one on this list
that says talking about your silly
crushes together we'll tell each other
about things like work crushes talking
about it makes it funny and we can laugh
about it instead of letting it build
into something real having a good laugh
about a stupid and human thing like a
crush makes us feel like we're in it
together and always choose each other so
that's someone's relationship
unconventional relationship hack
i i'm with you girls
do you want to die i'm sorry excuse me i
can see like a fictional like when you
talk about celebrity crushes anime
characters right things that you cannot
actually physically touch and possibly
do
that sounds like something in a marriage
maybe you've been together for a very
long time but early on in a relationship
when you're dating if i find out you you
think it's funny to tell me you have a
crush on a co-worker
that you're with eight hours out the day
oh yeah we're going to the workplace and
letting that [ __ ] up but that feels like
it would make me extremely insecure if
we're not at that place but if you've
been together for a long time that is
understandable right that sounds
different this is not new
relationship don't
yeah i think you have to evaluate at
what point in the relationship you're in
in order to apply these hacks
i was on a first date with a guy and
he's like i'm trying something new and
then he was like i'm you know like it's
all about communication you know i feel
like humans are not meant to be
monogamous i'm like okay here we go
what's up and he goes i feel like if you
just communicated things like you both
understand that no matter what you know
we are emotionally connected to each
other i come home to you and stuff a
little bit of flirting is not a bad
thing like looking at like if you tell
me like oh you're not allowed to look at
anyone else i'm like that's good too
much yeah that's extreme he's like but i
feel like if i were to go out and i like
i told a woman she was beautiful i
flirted a little bit but nothing
physical came out of it or whatever it
should be okay i was like
no
no no
he's like i'm looking for a relationship
where it's like we communicate so well
that you know we are allowed hall passes
well i'm sorry what you have an open
relationship unless you open a
relationship because no no like um
like i was like only i get the hall pass
no but he said no but you would too like
if you go on a girls trip you know
whatever happens happens i don't gotta
hear about it and this is the first date
this is the first date
well at least okay i will say this one
he's making it very clear how he's going
to be with you there is no confusion so
we'll give this man credit he knows what
he wants yeah he is not fooling you if
you were to be like yes okay and then
change your mind later on
and that's on you
um
but two did you get a second date did
you go on a second date no okay i was
gonna say it yeah so he was like you
know i know it's very unconventional but
i've done monogamy my whole entire life
this is also like
freshly new like
just came into money finance nft boy got
it you know like oh that's why
i will say that's smart on his part
because he is keeping your expectations
very real he is being upfront i will
applaud him for that he knows what he
wants he's not tricking you he's not
trying to sell you this dream to try to
get in bed with you you are an adult
you're both able to make decisions after
that and that is something that probably
more people need to do yes there's no
confusion and if it works out it works
out if it doesn't it doesn't but there's
nothing worse than thinking that someone
is going to be this gentleman and i i'm
all about i'm a one-woman type of man
and then you find out this is another
thing and then you find out it's
something else so you know what
i'm not even i'm happy you didn't go on
a [ __ ] second date because girl we
was going to have a whole other
conversation on the next podcast on how
your relationship didn't work and how we
told you yeah we could have told you
that from the first date but damn okay
so loki like impressed by him so yeah he
impressed but that does not make my
vagina want him no exactly i appreciate
it that you're telling me yeah because
we had the conversation of like when
you're dating in your 30s you straight
up have that conversation
yeah what do you want what do you not
want and when i said that i was like
okay
this is probably not gonna work out i'm
sorry yeah um which sucks he was so fine
but that doesn't mean like you've grown
too so you can decide like hey
maybe i
want to just have some fun yeah but like
i saw us at the same time like i don't
want you going on a bachelor party to
like another country like banging
hookers yeah and then like come home to
me and i'm like ooh that's kind of the
health issue there is not okay yeah but
i'm glad he was open about it it is very
unconventional yeah this is the
relationship i'm looking for that's
right yeah which is good for you right
but not for me yeah okay that's cool
yeah just like the whole like
being open about your crushes yeah yeah
that's a hard note for me don't tell me
that yeah i'm i'm with you guys on the
crushes thing too i mean i don't know
i'm married you're married i'm married
so you're married if casey has a crush
on someone i would want to know about it
rather than not know about it
but it also makes me feel some type of
way but
i don't have issues with talking about
like pointing out like beautiful women
or whatever oh she's
looks
all the time but because we like the
history of our relationship
we haven't built that that safety i
guess where he can feel comfortable to
say yeah she does have a nice ass yeah
because then we've we haven't gotten to
that point but at least
i can understand that part yeah like
trying to share
interest for other people
because a couple you're married yeah
yeah evaluate your relationship but that
can also bring in insecurities in your
relationship if you guys are not solid
exactly that's what i mean yeah
because if that feels like
say you're having a rough patch in your
relationship that would be a poor time
for him to think it's okay to talk about
oh yeah you know oh i find so and so
like attractive and you're like
that's not fun
right but also
y'all are good and you already had a
conversation about like yeah i would
rather you tell me than not tell me
because that's how you communicate so it
is unconventional and it works for some
but not um yep okay exactly let's see
what happens try it just try something
yeah don't don't you don't die all right
the second unconventional relationship
hack here is investing in separate
bedding so there's no fighting over
blankets during the night best thing you
can do for your relationship is to have
separate sheets
yup i know couples that have separate
rooms my co-worker talks about all the
time him and his wife um have their own
bedrooms and the main reason is because
his work schedule he wakes up at three
o'clock in the morning he has his
routine that he needs to do in order to
have a good day he doesn't want to
disturb her and honestly them splitting
rooms wasn't that they don't love each
other it was literally a necessity for
their relationship because they were
bickering and fighting over sleep over
the windows over the blankets over the
music over the like morning routine they
were just fighting and it works for them
my parents actually don't sleep in the
same room too
because my dad snores and my mom was
like yeah i can't sleep yeah you don't
realize that it's not that i don't love
you that i need to sleep somewhere else
but it's because hi i do love you and i
would like to continue loving you but at
this rate i
hate you every morning because you're
waking me up yeah or it's too hot or i'm
sweating or like nicole and steve they
have different bathrooms and they love
that yeah bathrooms are essential yeah
casey and i kind of have that like
there's one toilet that he'll use and
then i'll use the other toilet yeah but
i think separate bedding that's smart
that's a good that's an introduction to
you know say you don't have access to
other rooms and it's like it's not that
i don't want to lay on this sheet and
you don't want to fight over it's
something that's how you avoid a fight
yeah that saves you a petty stupid
argument it's about comfort it's okay
what i like may not be what you like and
we've seen so many people talk about
like
my wife got 72 pillows on this [ __ ]
bed and i don't know why she got all
these goddamn pillows on this bed and
every morning i gotta throw the pillows
off but there could be a compromise do
you know what i'm saying like maybe she
doesn't need 72 pillows maybe she could
compromise with you too and you guys can
have one less fight right that's a
little hack sometimes we don't always
gotta be right
but yeah there's two examples in here
about
them being married for 10 years and
preferring their own sleeping space like
their own bed or their own bed yeah i
almost stress a little bit thinking
about having to share my space one day
with somebody else again because i've
been
i sleep so soundly by myself i love it i
have my bed the way i want my feet
warmers go on at nine o'clock at night
i'm able to you know tell i'm going to
sleep at this time and it's cool i don't
have to worry about somebody wanting to
be up or do any of that things or like
sharing the bed i remember sharing a bed
with somebody and when they would roll
away from me why am i feeling some type
of way or we're fighting over the covers
or we have different work schedules and
it's kind of stressful thinking about
those fights i used to have that are so
petty that you don't have when you're
you know sleeping alone yeah you're
fighting with yourself didn't i tell you
to go to sleep at night yeah
i'm at onyx my dog
first off if if sharing a bed with a dog
is anything like sharing a med a bed
with a man again i don't want it yeah
this damn dog thinks he owns me and
that's what happens when you're in a
relationship they think they own you and
they just want to put their heavy ass
leg
on you and then when you tell them can
you please get your heavy ass leg off of
you i'm not being dramatic i'm
claustrophobic yeah okay
i just had a flashback
breathe sleeps he sleeps in between my
legs like i can't move this one
yeah but you're smaller than mine yeah
but he's annoying like he likes to sleep
either between my legs or on my face
like
your neck remember my ex used to love to
sleep on my face too yeah
and he steps right on my throat in the
morning
yeah i woke up choking every morning oh
wow
i remember those days wake up choking
every morning too yeah right there's
different reasons
he's like i've seen men do it to you
i'ma try it i heard you like it so
that's how he wakes me up in the morning
that's cute we're single
we're single hey
uh the next one is keeping finances
separate from one another separate bank
accounts as long as the mortgage and our
bills are paid you do you honey we've
been together for 12 years and i rarely
thought about money i think that's
important well now if
if
if it works for you if it works for you
yeah then good for you yeah because then
like for us we just we do have separate
bank accounts but we do have most of
everything going out of one account yeah
like it's easier because we're lazy yeah
and there was a point in time to where
women weren't even allowed to have bank
accounts so i think that this being a
newer hack is something that's probably
going to be normal for a lot of
women and just people in relationships
because
we see i hate to talk about divorce but
we see what divorce looks like and we
see so many people that are
are pretty much screwed if it doesn't
work out and they don't have anything
for themselves and it's not saying
having your own bank account is saying
that your relationship won't work it's
just the fact that you can have some
independence and you should be able to
at least know what's going to happen
with your life and i think that it's
great and you should share certain bills
make sure things are taken care of but
just like everything else communicate
and that has to do with trust
um i i can't see me having one just one
account i feel like that would be scary
to me and it would be a controlling
thing
for either i'm controlling my partner or
my partner is controlling me either way
i feel like that's what that would be
yeah if i didn't have um at least
something for myself right i like your
setup you share one but you also have
yeah yeah i like that
yeah yeah i think that's good yeah i
mean i tried thinking of it all that in
one account too and i'm like how crazy
would that be to ask permission right to
buy something yeah yeah
that's what so many people did
up until like not that long ago let's be
honest like and then the wives would get
an allowance yeah their husbands what
the [ __ ] like that would i well that's
because they don't work but but that's
but then that's also you know why it's
weird control it's a control thing but
that's why it is good to have a joint
and it's about communication and it's
about trust and it's also
that little bit of security that i feel
we all should have in case worst case
scenario you're just not asked out and
it's really sad that we've seen a lot of
people put all the eggs in one basket
and have no security uh no for
themselves exactly yeah unlike other
programs nume wait uses a psychology
based approach to help people better
understand their relationship with food
it teaches them how to be more mindful
of the way they eat and gives them the
skills and knowledge they need to build
long lasting positive habits here's the
thing i have probably tried every diet
on the planet because i was a female in
my 20s none of them were long-lasting
why because they didn't solve the
psychological aspects of why i was doing
the things i was doing and after the
diet was over i inevitably went back to
just the gross way that i was eating so
for me when i was going through the noon
program i found out that i am an anxiety
eater i just slam my mouth full of food
whenever i'm feeling anxious about
something this includes social
situations where i always have to have a
drink and or food in my hand that's not
healthy but i didn't realize it wasn't
healthy and i didn't realize that i was
packing on an additional pounds every
time i was going through a stressful
situation not to mention that your body
doesn't process food as well when you're
stressed out so it was a combination of
graze snacking when anxious and also
having too stressed to process uh the
food that i was consuming after getting
into healthy habits which nume helps you
develop you start to have more energy
you are keeping a food journal
understanding exactly what you are
eating every day super super helpful
stuff it doesn't take very much time out
of my day there's healthy exercises to
do it's just honestly ten minutes a day
do you have ten minutes a day one
thousand percent you do sometimes you're
like oh my god i don't have enough time
to go to the gym and work out for an
hour well do you have ten minutes yes so
you have no excuses go do this
seventy-five percent of new music finish
the program and every journey looks
different noon believes it's about
progress not perfection as is the rest
of life so start building better habits
for healthier long-term results sign up
for your trial today at noom that's n o
o m dot com slash big mood that's n o o
m dot com
big mood to sign up for your trial today
spring fever is in the air with the
smell of fresh blooms and the sun
shining down on us you can't help but
feel inspired to spice things up and
explore your inner desires and fantasies
find stories that match your mood this
season on dipsy dipsy is an app full of
hundreds of short sexy audio stories
designed by women for women they bring
scenarios to life with immersive
soundscapes and characters no matter who
you're into or what turns you on find
stories about that intriguing co-worker
with a british accent or hooking up with
your hot yoga instructor they even have
stories designed specifically for your
zodiac sign
leo stories should be really good new
content is released every week so in
between listening to your favorite
stories again and again you can always
find something new to explore dipsy also
has sleep stories wellness sessions and
now they also offer written stories it's
your go-to place to spice up your me
time explore your fantasies or heat
things up with a partner for our
listeners dipsy is offering an extended
30-day free trial when you go to
dipsystories.com
mood that's 30 days of full access for
free when you go to d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com moon again that's dipsy
stories.com
mood right next hack here says allowing
one another free passes so you can get
out of social occasions
one of you does not want to attend yes
yes that's pretty genius
my husband and i each have three free
passes a year to get out of events say
we were invited to dinner with my
college friends and he didn't want to go
he could use a free pass to get out of
it and there are no hard feelings yes my
ex
loved going to the movies and i did not
always want to go to the movies and that
and then like some some games like look
i love i love
my sports and i do like some movies but
i don't always like those things
i would tell them like you can go
by yourself or i we shared like a mutual
best friend i was like
take your friend out take him please i
don't want to go i hate feeling
obligated to always have to do [ __ ] that
i don't want to do because my partner
wants to and it should be okay to be
like yo
it's okay yeah and i need you to
understand that me not going isn't
because i don't love you i just don't
really want to go so please don't stop
doing what you enjoy doing
because there's nothing wrong and say
like a family event so now we don't have
to be real selective on when you choose
to not come to something that is
important to you yeah but if you're
saying no to a funeral [ __ ] you up yeah
yeah though
yeah those passes come with stipulations
you got to read the fine print you got
to talk it out yeah but i think that's
great i think that uh for some
relationships you don't have to do
everything together
and if that's not your relationship
though
communicate that yeah because
i wasn't always okay with that with my
partner
if he wanted to go and do something
without me or like i wanted him to come
with me and he didn't want to go i
probably would have been really upset
initially but as we spent so much time
together i was like
hey
you can go like you're asking me to go
to the movies you normally want to go to
the movies like you like can i can i not
go
but that took time and it also took like
this is i don't want you to think that
i'm not trying but now we've been
together so long that's like you might
need to be your own person again and i
just really don't want to go yeah right
i am
i dated a guy who loved partying
and
he would be he would get like upset like
because i don't want to go to a [ __ ]
club every weekend yeah we're in our 30s
yeah yeah
and then he'd be like if i don't go to
one or two like i feel like you never go
out with me and like i just want to you
know i'm like
but
i'll i will compromise and i will go
sometimes yeah but you can't give me
[ __ ] for not wanting to do something i
really don't like doing every time right
that's like me forcing you to go
shopping with me every time yeah if you
don't go i'm like what the [ __ ] you know
yeah so this is actually so healthy yeah
it also
it there's also a thing that i found out
or that i learned that i didn't like you
don't have to be involved in all my
hobbies
there's this one guy who's like i want
to play games with you all the time i'm
like look sometimes i just want to play
with my friends also you suck at games
yeah you know like yeah it frustrated me
when i played with him and if i didn't
like if he asked me to play and i said
oh not right now i'm gonna play with my
friends he gets angry like oh okay i see
yeah like don't do that like yeah go
find your own hobbies do your own thing
it's okay for couples to not do
everything yeah yeah
that's so true yeah or like if he's
playing a basketball game and i'm like
oh no i don't want to go right now he's
like i want you to come watch i don't
want to go this time he gets all mad
like fine yeah there's and there's
knowing that we can't do that all the
time
we can't be like i don't want because it
comes off that you don't support them
yes but having that pass
it is
also that is not probably something you
get right away that is earned that's
something that
you don't just get to use these hacks on
a new relationship and be like well i
heard it's super healthy that i don't do
everything i don't want to do so i'm not
gonna go and do it it's like no there's
a certain amount of effort that you put
in to earn that to be like hey
i know you hate this damn company i work
for i come home every day and i complain
about these people and it probably
really upsets you to even see them you
know what
it's okay that you don't want to go yeah
i understand why you don't want to go
it's not you not supporting me it's
actually probably what's best
and having that because i can totally
see why somebody wouldn't want to go to
a company event i think about some of
the stuff that i've said to my partner
or you know at that time and could only
imagine because when he's complained
about certain people i'm like i'm gonna
show up to this event and i'm gonna make
everybody's life hell i said guess what
if you're gonna make me come to this
we all suffer again and that's not
healthy i did that at a wedding
but that's a good piece of advice
because guess what you forced me to do
something i don't want to do and i don't
want to be here because what you're
going to not want to invite me again
yeah i don't know reading that it makes
me think about me and casey's
relationship when we totally have this
where remember we used to always go to
events and he would never come oh right
because he doesn't enjoy them yeah you
know what you want to make him go to a
makeup event yeah exactly
or like he doesn't enjoy them and then
plus like it i kind of enjoyed spending
time with my friend yeah we get to do
our own thing or he'll go to the movies
with his friends because he loves he's a
movies guys yeah he'll go to the movies
with his friends and i'm like cool you
go have a great time but he he is the
type of person that would like for me to
go with him so you may most of the time
but he doesn't mind though like he'll
he'll be really he won't make he won't
make me feel guilty for not going and i
don't i do the same to him like i don't
make him feel guilty for coming yeah not
coming because it's not an all the time
thing and you know anybody listening to
this right now it's not
every single time it's like hey i gotta
make compromises yeah but you can be
understanding enough to be like all
right here's your pass you get you got
one this year okay you can skip out on
the thanksgiving event with the damn
company but guess what you have to come
to christmas okay i understand
cool compromise
compromises yeah compromise that's the
word you
this next hack says
uh putting a spare room spare bedroom to
good use so we talked about like having
um an extra place to sleep like they
that's how they use their extra room
like having an extra bed in the guest
room so whenever one of us needs a quiet
night due to lack of sleep work stress
or anything else we sleep separate for
one night
but it could also be like a
you can have a game room yeah you can
use that spare bedroom for like quality
time too yeah just hopefully oh that
just sounded expensive part of me just
was like
i really hope these people i really hope
i find someone i can afford to have an
extra room with because i have my own
extra room oh yeah what do you use
mine is my little studio it's my little
office space
i used to keep it as a spare bedroom but
when the relationship didn't work out
because i was gonna keep it as that in
case we needed our own you know zones
but when that didn't work out i turned
it into my office and i've made it a
point to like wherever i stay
or um
move i always want to have that extra
space because i know how nice it can be
to get away it's um i need definitely
always have to have two bathrooms that's
a must i always have to have two
bathrooms at least and i have to have an
extra room so that just kind of made me
go wow i
i know some couples can't afford that i
mean i live in the bay area i 1000 know
what it is to not have the means to have
that that look that's a luxury uh so if
you don't have that extra room maybe
it's like that time to
allow your partner to leave maybe right
like go for a walk to kind of be
understanding that they need their space
find a safe place that they can go
because that's super scary i'm thinking
about like needing space for my partner
and imagining them sleeping somewhere
else it's like super
you know that could be really upsetting
but maybe it's like okay let them have
like
give them the living room give them like
a space of their own for like
don't be all up uh on them if you're in
like a one bedroom or a studio just kind
of mind
that maybe i feel like a lot of people
learn how to do that during the pandemic
yeah
yeah because yeah what you're saying
though too it's like that's totally how
we run our household like
we have to have three bathrooms one for
casey one for isaac and one for me yeah
yeah
and then we we always have to have like
an office now for casey to work and edit
but now that we have luca that spare
office
will eventually right now it's still in
office but it's going to be his bedroom
soon and we're like oh [ __ ] we we need
to buy a bigger house yeah we we can't
because then we're going to have to move
all the office stuff into our bedroom we
have space for the desk but then that's
just going to be like yeah we need to
separate it yeah if we can and depending
on your living situation
you got to figure out what works
for the both of you exactly
uh this next one
not watching tv separately this sounds
dumb but doing separate tvs most couples
i know one person will watch something
in the living room while the other will
go to a different place to watch
something different we like to give each
other's shows movie sports a chance and
we usually end up liking it or just
roasting it and having fun my boyfriend
has gotten me into horror movies this
way and i've slowly engulfed him into
the bachelor universe and trash reality
tv i like that because then you guys
find something to bond over
and i don't know i can't even imagine a
couple watching tv in separate rooms
i feel like for me when i think of that
i think of like old asian couples who
are clearly not in love anymore she's
watching tv in her living room he's in
his room and stuff you know i
just i just make that face because i
made that mistake that's a mistake i
made the mistake of not
watching something together yeah i
remember there was a lot of things but
it was also clearly we weren't in a good
place we needed our own
time uh when it was good of course like
compromise like i really don't want to
watch the shooting movie where
everybody's dying all the time before i
go to bed because i get nightmares but i
remember making the compromises and
that's when our relationship was good
and then i also remember not making it
anymore and wanting to watch things on
my own and that was ultimately kind of
leading out
of the relationship because yes it is
the almost like i'm no longer as
interested in the same things as you or
making the effort to try because like
they said you can you either love it or
you hate it and there's something
bonding
about that but there's something really
separating from one person being in
their space and you being in your space
and you're no longer talking about
what you're doing maybe if we came back
or they come back and they're like oh i
watch this and then like hey do you want
to watch it with me that's cool but the
completely separating your shows and
what you're entertained by just
puts such a wedge in the relationship
yeah kind of like how we do our ba our
finances we do that with tv shows
actually the three of us casey isaac and
myself like
we each have our own things that we
watch separately
because there's three tvs in our house
and and then there's the shows that we
watch like there'd be certain shows
where the three of us watched together
or there'd be certain shows where me and
isaac or isaac and casey or me and casey
and like we have like our own like yeah
shows that we're like oh you want to
catch up on that show that we've been we
love that yeah so i guess it's like
not not watching tv separately but yeah
also i don't know yeah even when i've
done long distance and i really like
like you we've tried to find shows that
we can watch or you know like one two
three plus play together yes i love that
it's really cute and when you don't do
that it's when you're like oh [ __ ] yeah
it's not working but i love getting a
show and watching it with the person
that i'm with you know whether it's like
you're like your best friend because
that's what you do with your friends
exactly you know so it's like when your
relationship is no longer a friendship i
feel like that's really what's showing
it's like i'm not interest we just don't
get along right we're not watching the
same things but when you do you have
you can make conversation you can make
jokes there's uh experience that you're
having so yeah i love oh my god did you
watch this new episode oh my god i
didn't watch a new episode again oh okay
i gotta watch the episode like i love i
love that for us it's like we can't we
watch it together yeah no no i would
we're going to stream this at the same
time what you can do on your phone
you can do this but it is yeah i would
get in trouble for watching something
before
it's frustrating there's nothing more
frustrating than waiting for someone to
watch something with you you're like i
want to watch it now they're like no i
got something to do i have a life
i'm gonna have to live and go to work
watch the show with me yeah
all right next one is
not giving gifts this one it says my
girlfriend and i don't do gifts for any
holidays or birthday birthdays but
instead we have been doing experiences
where we plan a day that the other
person would enjoy so for christmas i
plan a full day of things she would want
to do and she plans a day full of things
i would want to do rule is no
complaining we are opposite in a lot of
ways so it's fun
so it's uh fun ways to have our worlds
collide uh i don't like the whole
um no complaining kind of thing
i
you can have little gripes but if you're
not like fully complaining all the time
sure but this also comes down to like
love languages because gifts are my [ __ ]
yeah i love giving and receiving yes
yeah like i've been in relationships
before where it's like everything seems
great but i feel like oh you never give
me any like tokens of love that is my
love language that's how i grew up and i
can't stop myself from doing that for
you and it's not like extravagant gift
or whatever it's like hey i noticed you
have [ __ ] holes in your underwear i
bought you new underwear yeah
yeah but that's why i mean that makes
sense because it's unconventional that's
gonna work for some people i'm on the
same page as you i
think experiences are not something for
like holidays necessarily that's just
for me i think that we can do those
experiences or make it on not a holiday
we can have those days for us where we
have things like that um especially
depending on my partner but uh birthdays
christmas that's not i like i like gifts
i enjoy
receiving gifts but i also think that
that's a great idea for a different type
of day or maybe once a month we do that
instead to where it's like okay we have
an experience planned out or whenever
it's accommodating to the schedule
because sometimes i know depending on
who you're with it's really difficult to
prioritize that time and sometimes the
the gifts are like a token of
appreciation but for holidays like
they're saying they have a no gift and
no complaining
that you've got
first off
i don't know if i can go and let
somebody plan a whole day for me really
really would i
i feel like maybe one person i feel like
one person that i've been with would
know how to right um i have a control i
have control issues and i'm learning
that's one of the things i'm trying to
learn how to like let go of because i
just want to be taken care of and i
think that would be so much fun yeah but
if i'm not allowed to complain
i still like gifts so no yeah i don't
think i'm not giving up my birthday just
for a thing i i think that gifts are
really sweet and i like people who like
giving gifts so yeah
i i think i would agree with these
people
um what they're saying so
currently in our relationship we do give
each other gifts
but
every because like i'm kind of in the
middle because i do like receiving gifts
especially the gifts that casey gives me
they're so
like thoughtful and romantic and like
there's a lot of like love put into them
so i really love them
receiving them though it like makes me
panic where i'm like how am i going to
live up to this gift and give you a gift
that's just like this okay like i i
don't enjoy that part or i'm like [ __ ] i
want to give you back the emotion that
you gave he's just better he's better at
giving gifts yes yeah he is he's way
better at giving gifts and so for that
reason i prefer the experiences route
and that to me is
like super valuable too
i don't know like the thing is can there
be like a hybrid like i'm split because
then like the actual the tangible gift i
can relive and re
have those emotions over and over and
over and over again but then like an
experience it is kind of like a one-time
thing but it's a memory that i can
always look back on and it's an
experience that we shared together and
for me experiences are like way more
important than physical tangible things
so i'm really in the [ __ ] middle
about it i think a hybrid situation
would be beautiful for
check it right now we're planning our
10-year anniversary we've been together
for 10 years
um and five years married and so we
decided we're like because i'm really
stressed about it because i'm like [ __ ]
you you always get the best gifts yeah
i'm like can we just do no gifts this
time and like this time like let's plan
a because we're gonna be in vegas for
our shoot it's the thursday before our
big mood shoot in vegas and this is
gonna be again in may okay may 21st our
anniversary is the 19th so i was like
okay how about this year
or like for this big occasion
let's just plan a day together and like
let's just do ex vegas together
experiences together so that's kind of
what we agreed on and we first were like
wait should we surprise each other with
things and i was like yeah but what like
scheduling conflicts like yeah let's
just do it together yeah yeah so that's
kind of how we but would you be upset if
he still got you a gift though
i would feel bad
is it why would you feel bad because i
feel like i i would need to reciprocate
does he believe that though exactly no
but
because every time that you give a gift
do you expect a reciprocation from him
no so you should expect that from him
too
you know what i think it is like the
real thing i think it's the public
opinion that gets to me [ __ ] that that's
what gets to me because then like he'll
give me like super sweet things and then
people were like wow what did tiff get
him so like but also you don't have to
really don't either but yeah so [ __ ]
those people [ __ ] those people because
i've been in a situation where the
person has everything they have
everything there's nothing that i can
give of that's of like
necessary yeah that is going to compare
but i also know that that's not what
it's important to that person and it
[ __ ] was terrible initially because
the gifts that i would receive are like
amazing like oh my god how the [ __ ] am i
supposed to you know compare and it
became a problem to where i didn't want
to receive gifts anymore that i felt bad
and i wasn't acknowledging the fact that
that's how they show love but they don't
even care like if i was to buy them
something expensive you'd probably be
like take this back like what i don't
need this it's almost like oh now i'm
just doing it
for whatever other reason but i would do
activities instead so like setting up a
massage like getting the full table
doing the like like setting up um
the whole room because that's something
that money can't money can't buy this i
did this all myself i put in the effort
and they appreciated that so when they
would give gifts i would
return with like my gift would be like a
gesture or something that i know would
actually make them happy they used to
ask for like paintings can you paint me
something like uh draw me something
that's what i care about i can get you i
can wind up with a bag
and they'll be like i don't want you to
go spend money and buy me something
expensive in return but can you put
effort into something creative because i
know that that's you showing love the
way that i like buying something for you
so i was like okay cool but i think
because of your circumstances with
everybody having an opinion
if
somebody's listening and knows about
your relationship and would understand
that that's not even his love language
and to buy him something for someone
else is the opposite of what you're
supposed to be doing for your
relationship yeah well it's because the
hard thing is too like
casey doesn't want anything ever or like
no experiences no tangible things like
no nothing so i'm like so he's hard to
do for you and he's like i don't want
nothing and i'm like i can't just do
nothing
and then he's like just do nothing i'll
be happy that's hard fine do nothing and
then i'm like
that's tough look if you're listening
and you're judging her relationship yeah
she got amanda like to take care of her
treat her good and by her gifts go get
you one like so
that's kind of what it comes down to
like hey he loves taking care that's his
love language y'all need to figure out
how you can show him love yeah in your
way too but yeah man i think that's the
part where i'm like [ __ ] 10 years in i
still don't know how to
but
but at the same time like it shouldn't
matter what anybody else's opinion is
because i've seen tons of couples that
are so showy with their gifts and he's
cheating on her yeah he's buying her all
the things and she's buying him all the
things and look at us we're a boss
relationship and y'all are sleeping with
other people and refuse to tell
everybody the truth about your
relationship and haven't actually been
together in years and you're broke so
if you're you know so many
you're poor and they're doing all that
just for public image not for each other
right yeah yeah i've seen that before
and then this they it was exactly that
look at all these red bottoms he bought
me and then one night she drunkenly
posted someone please
i'm not happy he beats me oh jeez you
know it's like don't do things for
public image like that
yeah your own relationships yeah so if
you're worried about people judging you
girl they can judge you regardless yeah
they're happy yeah so you know what if
you want to not get your man anything
don't and if you want to get your man
something get him something see that's a
thing too another thing and then i'm
going to drop this okay is that
i want to give him stuff too and so like
i'll try to give him a gift
but then like because he doesn't like
it's not his thing like he will just
throw it in a drawer and never look at
it so i'm like oh well then but then you
all gotta have a conversation maybe no
we did no no he doesn't do that anymore
it was like for years i'm like but i
gotta do that and you never touched it
and blah blah blah and i'm like ah see
you guys are just stressful for me
they're just like can we just go and do
something nice that's why for mother's
day he [ __ ] nailed it and he took me
to a rage room so i'm like oh yeah yes
see that's awesome yeah that's
ultimately what a relationship is about
is getting to know the person and you
know what he's happy because you're
happy and you're happy when he's happy
so there you go exactly
and now it's time to shout out one of my
favorite sponsors ritual the amazing
multivitamin i've been taking ritual for
so long now i took it throughout my
entire pregnancy and now i'm actually
taking their post-natal vitamins and
they're so great because as i'm
breastfeeding they actually have more uh
nutrients in there that is very
beneficial for my breastfeeding body but
you know what gaps in the diet should
not be ignored because over 97 of women
age 19 through 50 are not getting enough
vitamin d from their diet and 95 are not
getting the recommended daily intake of
key omega-3s rituals essential for women
18 and over multivitamin was formulated
by exhaustive research to help fill
nutrient gaps in the diets of women ages
18 and up it is formulated with
nutrients to help support brain health
bone health blood health and provide
antioxidant support but ritual didn't
stop there they invested in a gold
standard university-led clinical trial
to prove the impact of essential for
women 18 and over multivitamin and the
results it turns out that this
multivitamin was shown to increase
vitamin d levels by 43
and omega-3 dha levels by 41 in 12 weeks
that clinical study was published in
leading scientific journal frontiers in
nutrition ritual is committed to
third-party testing from usp and non-gmo
project traceable and vegan friendly
ingredients and always clear
communication
no shady stuff i highly recommend ritual
it's just high quality vitamins i
absolutely love them and ritual is
offering our listeners 10 off during
your first three months visit ritual.com
big mood and turn healthy habits into a
ritual that's 10
off at ritual.com
big mood all right next unconventional
relationship hack is showering together
i love showers
i gotta love hate with that one yeah
i shampoo his hair how cute i wash his
body and he does it for me too and it's
like yeah sweetest like um and i have a
bench in my shower where like he'll just
sit there and i'm like shampooing his
hair we're talking and stuff and then i
clean him up and then he does the same
thing for me yeah i think it's the
cutest thing in the whole time yeah i
love showering together so much the only
thing i don't like uh i do like
showering together and i was actually
telling i was telling you in the room
how i love being bathed like i love
being washed like that to me is so
like loving and there's a lot of care
and it's just like
such a beautiful moment and i enjoy that
and showering together i'm definitely
for showering together
but no shower sucks please
overrated yeah but
i hate when i can't get my hair wet
there's like certain there's like
certain things right so i can't get my
hair away and you're you know when
you're in a solid-ass relationship with
somebody that understands the importance
of baby please don't get my hair wet
because this is we can't get my hair wet
it's going to curl
that is a nice place to be um but also i
cannot stand because i'm a taller person
um and i date tall people when you're
standing there and you're right at his
shoulder and the water is beating off
his shoulder into your eyes
and then you just sit over here getting
water shot in your face and you're
trying to be cute and your contact is
moving on your eye
and i also hate when one person is
hogging the shower and you gotta like
rotate through so you got to make sure
that it's warm in the bathroom yeah
you have to
showering together can be amazing but
it's an experience and i think that part
of it makes it even better too because
it can be funny yeah um but i hated when
i didn't want to shower with somebody
because they thought that i didn't care
about them but i'm like i just don't
want to go that's shaped by coochie
leave me alone
or it's like i wish they would be like
i'll do it for you i don't know where it
is
like the person i was with i was like i
love you
i wanna shave you and i'll let you do
the same for me
yeah but i can't do this all the time
like you gotta understand not all the
time sometimes i just want to rinse the
[ __ ] off yeah yeah for us it's because
we like different water temperatures oh
really for him it's like
super hot shower oh for me it's like
lukewarm oh hold on because i've seen
the memes yeah they say women you know
that boiling hot showers they say like
they love it so hot because it's the
closest thing that they it reminds them
of their home in hell yeah where they
came from right every man i've been with
they like the hot water and i'm like
this [ __ ] is too [ __ ] hot it's way
too hot way too much and then casey has
sensitive skin so i'm like you're
hurting your skin you're right now
you're supposed to do this stop hurting
yourself you're hurting yourself because
then it gets all dry and cracking and
then he's not going to use lotion no
yeah he does and always because he has x
i'm up too i was like you got to loosen
your man up
but i'm like the hot water makes it
worse yeah no totally like dude what are
you doing so wait are we all deciding
that showering together is a good thing
i'm like i love it
ah i think that it shouldn't be all the
time but it definitely should be
something you do together yeah there you
go for sure yeah i like that bathe my
baby
oh i love it they luffer me up
i loof them up and i get clean like i
get all in there i love it and that's
like you said it's a very nurturing
thing i love it but don't let me sit in
the [ __ ] hot tub for too long
that's another story
well there's some more relationship
packs uh in the link in the description
but thank you guys for watching let me
know if you guys have other
unconventional relationship hacks yeah
um i'm sure there's
a ton i mean there's more in this list
but yeah let's just be real most
relationships are unconventional and
whatever the norm was
forget the knowledge actually i i got
one for us uh i don't know if it's a
hack or whatever but for in our
relationship
casey is the one that likes to be in the
kitchen he likes to cook and i'm the one
that likes to be the handy person around
the house that's unconventional because
yeah usually guys are the handymen and
girls are the chefs or whatever the
cooks so i'm like yeah there's something
in our relationship
i love that i um like uh i was seeing
someone who was a chef
and i love it i just realized and that's
when i realized like i like being the
baby i sit here and then he brings me
food you know it's the cutest thing ever
i love it yes yeah yeah i love being
babied and spoiled too and i didn't
realize that and so i stopped caring how
anybody else looked at me like i thought
i needed to be misindependent
immediately needed to be able to do
everything on my own but my thing is is
i can be independent i just choose don't
want to not to be
i don't want to have to be independent
all the time and i
love that so if you want to baby me and
somebody else doesn't like how you spoil
me or treat me well [ __ ] them because
i'm not dating them meeting you exactly
do what works for you
yeah all right guys thank you for
watching make sure to check out nikki
blaze yes check me out 99 seven now big
bay mornings monday through friday from
6 a.m i wake up early until 10 a.m where
you can check in on streaming also at
nikki blades on instagram no chaser
podcasts we are there every wednesday
with a new post and superb sportswear oh
and my food page nikki street eats yeah
gina oh hi yeah i stream that's all you
can just check me on twitch.tv uh slash
miss gina darling and on g4 tv yeah yeah
and my family channel tiffin case anyway
check out our sponsors support the show
we love you bye thanks we'll see you
guys next time love you bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you